so today I decided I would go out of my
comfort zone which is my little pond
my little ocean if you will and do a
little bit of shopping it's almost
summer or actually summer is here so I
thought that I would like to get some
new outfits so that I could find myself
a sexy man I want to go see if they've
got fishing poles back this with not
look good on my figure so we've got nuts
like this he's nice t-shirts this way
there's fishing poles yeah not good
today I go upstairs crawl good school us
something I forget how old I think you
guys are not familiar but when you're
looking for a man you've got or get a
fishing pole because you've got find a
good catch how to find a man I love stir
man this is this is completely separate
from anything that you guys might be
into if you're into lobster men I've got
what you need first step to finding a
man find some bait I am the beat so I've
got to hook myself onto something
I just got yelled at it was told that I
cannot film here but I'm not filming I'm
trying to run myself a man made you not
understand now I've got believe I'm
never gonna find myself a man let's go
get ourselves sexy swimmies
I'm not quite sure - do I think
getting our best interest to leave him
alone he's taking a little nap let's go
to the mall
shall we it's crazy because I feel like
I'm being discriminated against
I got kicked out of the Gander Mountain
my first stop is going to be two of the
Victoria's our secrets and stuff
sometimes I'm not quite sure the secrets
or but I'll tell you what my secrets are
I hope I could fill myself something
sexy I think I might need to get a
measurement to just see what I am 36 be
had these sizes work area good how are
you good do you think them how what do
you think my size would be why can't
tell under that under shell do you guys
have swimsuits no we don't know I think
I might just get some underwear did
they've got collection for what on the
way different then no show phones no
she's uh yes um thank you never either
333 perfect thing can you get on your
arm trolling I think I can get it I do
thank you so sexy all the boys are gonna
be the pawn how do you print please
thank you yeah we don't have paper won't
have from thank you
I'm gonna be singing those milkshake
brings all the boys to the yard
damn right it's better than yours a den
right it's better than you're the
teacher but I have to charge as if a boy
let's see if we got were here Fisher we
all hi dear fish oil just like a little
bottle that looks good perfect thank you
so much oh all I'm going to Red Lobster
after and when I'm out of the ocean too
long I've got to get my supplements
makes total sense right
I'm actually oh don't tease me like that
because I wanted to Gander Mountain was
looking for a fishing pool to find
myself a man I do this that sounds quite
fantastic are you a fast swimmer look at
sharks chase it's true Shark Week is
coming up my friends get they get all
the television where are you from
Oh from the ocean I think people say I'm
from New Zealand oh I've got a bear here
I'll just put it in my Victoria's Secret
bag I'll box and underwear squat nice
lobster and some underwear you've got
any sexier but not you know what I think
said we're gonna find out perfect well
thank you so much be sitting under the
sea see you it is always green it's
somebody else's like I dream about going
up there that is a big escape I think
those are the words I'm not sure
under the seagull another C oh I got
fish oil she owned a hot topic I bet I
can find a nice t-shirt and what if
they've got only Slayer t-shirts do you
have you guys have any snare t-shirts
and it was layer t-shirts yes
yes ah probably working probably like a
large maybe for you it's for me you look
pretty tireless see underneath me
Michelle well everything in the store is
buy one get one half ah oh yeah I ask
why our dresses are lost
well I'm going to Red Lobster actually a
tall t-shirt I was I'm mad enough time
thank you
a great day yeah swim by you later
hello yes I was just want to how much
for piercings or just like my little it
depends on whatever ear ring you to sign
you have to wear gold well I would just
like it maybe like what over here
what are we piercing is it called exhale
my my exoskeletons I can't even keep a
straight face a um yeah so I'll just
look just like a seriously you're not
piercing your ear this just rock through
there okay yes it's out so its
exoskeleton not sure if you guys have
done this here before oh my god no
well you know what there's a first for
everything and this is quite exciting I
think I'm into this one Assessor spike
stud you like the spoon we do I just
bought a slayer t-shirt so it's going to
get quite nice with it
wait I think I might have to change my
mind I found an anchor we don't Pierce
with these ones okay just kidding
I like weather you gotta buy those for
half off I will do that actually
confusing it's okay so I am gonna get
Pierce so just pierce through more
exoskeleton I'm gonna buy that and I'm
gonna buy the stainless steel to be
pierced we could do both sides if you
think that would look good
I've gotten credit card so in a hurry up
okay but I have to ask a question why
are we piercing their focus good is what
it's my body and I want to be pretty
we're gonna make it as a partly now
we're just marked at as in your alarm
yes falling okay
there's no exoskeleton option I don't
think I trot when I went to Gander
Mountain I was trying to find myself a
hook but these are actually clong cuter
[Music]
do you like my piercing look I got my
exoskeleton look at it look at it with
your eyes take a peek do you like it
tell me that you like it no she doesn't
even care but it's okay because I've got
this too this is something like a get
into something I could get behind
Oh can't see
I can't see I can't see
let's go to Red Lobster this is this is
bollocks I got to get myself some
biscuits oops I said I'm Michelle didn't
mean to say I'm Michelle I'm done
what's up shadi
there are scare I'm done so over this
right now it's because I need a beer
like I need a serious a Golic beverage
without the alcohol with the alcohol